salut aujourd'hui on va fermer cette
géode watts incroyablement facile je
pensais pas qu'ils auraient si peu de
résistants comment 49,3 finalement
allons observer cette job dans mon
accélérateur de particules déjà me dit
trop bien jefo approche petit ou là un
peu moins voilà là c'est bien avant
d'aller plus loin la découverte des
merveilleuses merveilles de notre
sous-sol et reste un truc à savoir et ce
truc c'est que la géologie n'est pas une
science c'est bien plus que ça c'est une
vocation c'est une philosophie c'est une
grammaire c'est un cap c'est une
péninsule c'est une fille félicitations
nous l'appellerons mehdi lui plus
sérieusement le dernier truc à savoir
pour mériter votre ceinture blanche en
géologie c'est qu'il existe trois types
de roches celles qui comprennent la
logique celle qui ne la comprennent pas
et les autres les premiers à s'être
formée sur terre c'est les roches
magmatiques c'est du magma qui a
refroidi pour donner des roches
magmatiques jusqu'ici ça va mais c'est
un peu comme les mesures du gouvernement
en matière d'écologie ça manque un pote
concret munissez-vous tout d'abord d'un
magma bon aphatie d'ailleurs vous avez
pas besoin d'acheter votre mac mahon
supermarché un vous pouvez très bien de
cuisine et vous même il vous suffit pour
cela de prendre une péridotite de la
chauffer de la comprimer et ou d'y
ajouter de l'eau ce qui permet
d'abaisser le point de fusion de la
roche en gros elles font un plus basses
températures et paf ça fait du magma
cette belle pâte plus ou moins visqueuse
là d'où son nom d'ailleurs ça vient du
grec massein qui veut dire pétrir
malaxer et contrairement à ce qu'on
pense en général le magma n'est pas
complètement liquide il ya aussi des gaz
dissous et des grumeaux qui se baladent
dedans c'est soit des bout de caillou
arraché à la roche encaissante ou tout
simplement d'être des minéraux qui n'ont
pas fondu ou qui viennent de se former
et c'est pour ça qu'on parle de fusion
partielle de la roche
et oui souvenez-vous dans un magma tous
les minéraux ne cristallise pas la même
température l'olivine se forme dans un
four bien chaud alors que quartz se
contente d'une fin de cuisson pour
prendre les deux extrêmes c'est pareil
dans l'autre sens le quartz faudra à
basse température le living à haute
température et c'est pour ça qu'on se
retrouve avec du liquide et du solide
qui sont mélangés en espèce de gros tas
informe comme votre soeur donc pour
l'instant on est sous terre à partir de
là vous avez deux options soit votre
magma reste là et il refroidit bien p
pouces ou alors il remonte en surface et
il nous fait un volcan qui resterait
dans le premier cas on obtient des
roches plus tonique parce que cette
poche de magma là une fois refroidie on
appelle ça un pluton et comme notre
soupe refroidi tout doucement ses atom
ont le temps de faire connaissance avec
leurs voisins et leur tenir la main pour
former des
aux cristaux qu'on voit à l'oeil nu
comme le granit ça faisait longtemps que
j'avais pas dégainé suis là tous les
minéraux se touchent comme des youtuber
une convention ils sont bien gros bien
visible c'est magnifique c'est ce qu'on
appelle une texture grenu et ça c'est
typique des roches plus tôt nous c'est
ce qu'on retrouve en bretagne par
exemple les côtes d'armor pour
simplifier c'est un peu ton donc une
poche de magma qui a refroidi pour
donner du granit mais si on regarde ça
plus près c'est pas un pluton c'est
plusieurs en chasser les uns dans les
autres
le premier est apparu il s'est ensuite
fracturé et du magma est remonté dans
les trous qui un refroidissement nous a
donné un deuxième plutôt ce fameux
granit rose et refacture re pluton ainsi
de suite à la va comme je te pousse donc
en très très très très gros et de loin
les spécialistes vont me tuer les côtes
d'armor c'est des poupées russes de
pluton est tout de suite
la confirmation en image de notre
correspondant local bretagne limousin
voilà donc pour nos rouge pitonner qui
du côté des volcans c'est beaucoup plus
rock'n'roll quand le magma atteint la
surface et qui devient de la lawe cette
lave
une fois refroidie nous donne des roches
volcaniques comme le basalte la
particularité des roches volcaniques
séquelles son souffle et on l'a vu dans
le magma en fait il ya aussi des gaz
dissous et ces gaz s'échappe avec quand
ça remonte en surface par une toute
petite cheminée ses rangs sous pression
et du coup ça va donner généralement des
roches plein d'air soufflé donc assez
légère et quand les dieux géologique des
bouches des volcans telle une bonne
bouteille de mousseux la lave est
expulsé plus ou moins violemment comme
des migrants aux portes de l'italie
c'est un peu la panique à bord et du
coup ces atomes ont pas le temps de se
dire bon alors comment on va rester là
encore un peu fois bob tu prends la
cabine 58 jacqueline tu prends la 12 jan
saucisson l'a4 dense et plus sauf qui
peut arrêt sur image générique de fin
donc comme la roche est refroidi
brutalement les minéraux sont plus
petits ils n'auront pas le temps de
pousser ce qui fait qu'on les verra
rarement l onu on appelle ça une texture
micro lithiques et si on regarde tout ça
au microscope on verra qui baigne dans
un espèce damas amorphe comme votre
soeur après son avc ces fameuses atom
complètement en vrac qui ont pas eu le
temps de s'organiser pour nous voler
notre travail c'est ce qu'on appelle du
verre est le cas le plus extrême
c'est ça du verre de l'obsidienne pour
les intimes et on le reconnaît à sa
cassure très typique qu'on appelle une
cassure concots idal c'est un peu la
même que vous avez quand vous cassez a
un cul de bouteille en verre par exemple
c'est un mot que j'aime beaucoup
concordat
d'ailleurs j'espère que vous allez
réutilisé par exemple quand vous verrez
une bataille d'ivrognes en match et vous
pourrez vous baissez les ramasse un bout
de verre et montre aux gens quel surcoût
qaïda mais ils sont tellement heureux
d'avoir appris un truc
grâce à vous qui vont arrêter de se
quereller et qui vont plutôt se battre
ensemble pour un avenir meilleur
et voilà pour les roches volcaniques
donc figurez vous que l'on trouve aussi
en bretagne ça tombe bien c'est un peu
le paradis des géologues la bretagne
finale et pas uniquement pour son porto
sa morue et son temps sur la presqu'île
de crozon il ya des anciennes coulées de
lave sous marine des coussins basalte
qu'on appelle aussi pilot lava qui ont
450 millions d'années donc à près d'un
demi milliard d'années la bretagne était
déjà sous l'eau sauf qu'à l'époque il y
avait des volcans en plus la légende
raconte qu'il crachait du caramel au
beurre salé retour en duplex avec notre
correspondant local finistère
alpes-maritimes donc pour résumer parmi
les roches magmatiques notre première
catégorie on a d'une part les roches
plus tonique qui cristallise en
profondeur elles sont toutes belles tout
grenu et d'autre part les roches
volcaniques qui se forme en surface et
qui sont soufflées comme comme vous
quand vous verrez cette vidéo et ça avec
le même matériau de base du magma si
bien qu'on arrive à en faire des couples
de roche ou une même composition de
magma si la roche refroidi en profondeur
ce sera un granit et si elle refroidit
en surface ce sera une rihanna en
profondeur si c'est un gars bros en
surface est en basalte et cetera et
cetera
[Musique]
eh bien vous savez quoi on y est on y
reste les bretons n'ont pas que des
roches magmatiques des chapeaux ronds
des andouilles les le mont saint michel
est un taux record de nitrates dans leur
dos ils ont aussi un deuxième type de
roche que j'aime beaucoup les roches
métamorphiques regardez moi ces beautés
ce sont des cailloux qui ont été
malmenés par la vie du coup elles
changent d'apparence comme tata ou dette
avant et après les témoins il bien que
c'est la même personne mais elles se
ressemblent pas du tout et bien là c'est
pareil si vous compris mais une roche
dans une chaîne de montagnes en
formation ou vous la chauffer sans aller
jusqu'à la faire fondre non plus à la
métamorphose et son reflex à cette
pauvre auch cas rien demandé ça peut
être de créer des nouveaux minéraux
comme la tourmaline où les grenats ou
bien alors de faire des feuillets en
gros la roche aligne ses minéraux sous
l'effet de la contrainte comme quand on
est dans le métro en heures de pointe et
que la ram est déjà pleine à craquer
mais qui a quand même 50 ans b s'il qui
monte dedans on sera serré du coup on va
prendre moins de place en largeur et on
va tous grandir de 20 cm cic
scientifiquement prouvé bon alors
contrairement à nous les minéraux ou en
plus aligner tous les uns à côté des
autres ce qui peut être utile pour
laisser le passage à à ceux qui
voudraient entrer et sortir de la ram
par exemple nous on n'en est pas là
c'est à dire qu'on est moins évoluée que
des schistes sauf en corée du nord bien
sûr parce que là bas les gens sont bien
disciplinée ça arriverait pas là bas ils
font pas des grèves à tout va puisqu'on
parle de schiste un exemple ordinaire
celle ardoise cm sur laquelle vous
écrivez que vous étiez à l'école parce
que vous avez 80 ans bien celle sur
laquelle vous mangez votre burger sans
gluten avocat thon rouge avec sas au
sommet de goji et sa salade de graines
germées arrosé d'une pointe d'ail pia et
brassait artisanalement mais y'a pas que
les schistes et ligue nice il y en a
aussi d'autres les marbres les
écologistes les amphis bolide les méta
gabbro bref y'en a plein et ce qui est
magique c'est qu'on peut reconstituer ce
à quoi ressemblait tata odette avant
l'été par reconstituer c'est un bien
grand mot mais en tout cas on peut
généralement savoir que c'était une
caucasienne de 50 ans qui regardent
scènes de ménage et pas pour la poitrine
de vignes à l'ardoisé par exemple
c'était largy compact l amphi bolide
c'était du basalte le marbre c'était du
calcaire mais bref je m'égare
et mais attendez là argilo-calcaires on
n'avait pas encore parlé de ça ce serait
pas des exemples du troisième type de
roche mais oui les roches sédimentaires
mon cher watson
je vous ferai pas l'affront de vous
expliquer que c'est des sédiments
transformer en rush donc les roches
sédimentaires c'est des sédiments
transformer en roche si vous vous
rappelez notre bienheureux sable raul
d'un épisode précédent sur raul est né
de l'érosion du nôtre roche c'est un
sédiment le plus triste c'est que raul
peut redevenir une roche du grès ce
grèce est un exemple de roches
sédimentaires détritiques formé comme
son nom l indique de détritus
c'est aussi le cas du poudenx à une tête
de nos gars sauf que ce n'est pas du
tout en fait c'est une plage de galets
fossilisés t'adore longs cous org
mais vous vous serez douter il ya
d'autres types de roches sédimentaires
évidemment celle d'origine chimique qui
sont formés quand l'eau s'évapore et que
certains éléments qu'elle contient
précipite c'est comme ça qu'on obtient
le sel et enfin les roches d'origine
biogénique celle dont on a un peu parlé
dans la vidéo sur le sable c'est celle
qui se forme au fond des lacs des
rivières et des océans par une joyeuse
accumulation de cadavres et oui parce
qu'un beau jour les baleines les
poissons le plancton tout ça ça meurt et
quand ça me va at on offin l'océan et
chacun une espèce de neige féerique
comme ça chaque couche va l'écraser un
peu plus la précédent et ce cimetière
marin va finir par sa durée et donner du
calcaire parce que les squelettes sont
en quelqu'un comme noah nous finalement
et voilà le travail
[Musique]
et si vous me demandez quel est mon
calcaire préféré c'est une question un
peu bizarre mais après tout pourquoi pas
alors je vous montrerai ceci douvres
calais le d-day le jour le plus long
débarquement immédiat qu'est ce qu'on a
fait au bon dieu
les visiteurs en amérique les bronzés 3
ils souvenirs intenses des plus sombres
moments de notre histoire la craie donc
c'est un type de calcaire très pur
constitué uniquement de squelette d'une
famille de phytoplancton qu'on appelle
coccolithophores idées et je sais pas si
je préfère leur nom ou leur tête ce que
regardez moi ces bouilles et voilà donc
pour les roches sédimentaires c'est des
sédiments un durée qui sont au choix
d'origine détritiques chimiques
biogénique et c'est dans ces roches là
on trouvera des faux ciel uniquement
dans celle là si vous en trouvez dans
des roches sédimentaires c'est qu'il ya
une poule dans le cottage point
bécassine reprenons notre l'avons
coussin cette lave a coulé au fond de
l'océan sur des sédiments et ben c'est
en regardant les fossiles contenues dans
ces roches sédimentaires autour qu'on a
pu dater les pilot l'avant qu'est-ce
qu'ils étaient de la même époque
et voilà donc tout est connecté et c'est
même pire que ce que vous prouver tout
est tellement connectés qu'on parle
carrément de ce cycle géologique si vous
prenez n'importe quel rush vous la
faites fondre ça devient du magma plus
une roche magmatique vous et rodez
n'importe quel rush en fait une autre
avec les restes ça devient une roche
sédimentaire comme un grève vous
chauffez comprimé une roche magmatique
ou sédimentaires salam et amorphis comme
cette ardoise et vous pouvez les rodez
ou la transformer en magma à nouveau si
ça vous chante
et ainsi de suite ce cycle là ça nous
paraît une évidence à nous autres
géologues c'est le genre de truc qu'on
apprend en arrivant à la fac mais
figurez vous que ça fait pas si
longtemps qu'on le sait l'idée est
apparemment né à la fin du xviiie et
elle aurait mis plus d'un siècle a gagné
le coeur et l'intellect de la communauté
scientifique tout commence chez les
lumières écossaise dans la tête de james
rate c'est un peu le père de la géologie
moderne et accessoirement le brut de
david youm et adam smith pour ceux
d'entre vous qui sont cultivées pour
monsieur fils du coup en 1785 james
righton expose sa toute nouvelle théorie
de la terre à la société royale
d'edimbourg il s'est dit et si notre
planète bleue était en fait une poubelle
jaune et si elle passait son temps à se
recycler prenez du matériel fondue qui a
entraîné dans les montagnes montagne qui
sont érodées ça dégringole jusqu'au mer
où ça devient une roche sédimentaire me
connaissez la chanson là maintenant il
se dit je cite
ouvrez les guillemets
même les plus vieilles branches sont des
wind ancien continent pays baptise ce
grand vide des cailloux le grand cycle
géologique j'ai obligé mais pas le café
cette idée s'inscrit dans une théorie
plus large
esquissée par tom puis affiné et raffiné
par le géologue écossais encore un
charles la botte de darwin ils ont
remarqué que les processus impliqués en
géologie était très très lent vous
pourrez pas vous construire une
résidence secondaire en pierre avec le
calcaire qui pousse dans vos
canalisations par exemple a tout de
suite en tout cas ils se sont dit si ça
se trouve c'est les mêmes processus
conforme et la terre qu'il connaît
maintenant mais sur des échelles de
temps gigantesque du coup on n'a même
pas besoin d'invoquer dieu des
illuminati où des extraterrestres pour
expliquer les formations géologiques
qu'on observe aujourd'hui coucou damian
il suffit de regarder comment marche la
nature et d'imaginer la même chose sur
des échelles de temps on gigantesque en
d'autres mots le présent est la clé du
passé ça c'est ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui le principe d' actualiser et
c'est un des piliers de la géologie
moderne aujourd'hui ce principe repose
sur deux éléments
premièrement le principe de régularité
si ça se passe comme ça aujourd'hui
maintenant ça se passait peut-être déjà
comme ça y est et deuxièmement le
principe de simplicité ou rasoir d'occam
pourquoi faire compliqué quand on peut
faire simple
en d'autres termes on va déjà essayer
d'expliquer un maximum de choses avec
les hypothèses qu'on a déjà admis avant
de penser en ajouter d'autres
le paléontologue stephen jay gould le
mec du gène égoïste là a commenté ça en
disant waouh génial vous venez dire que
la géologie s'appuie sur les mêmes
principes que toutes les sciences
expérimentales donc la géologie est une
science cool cool cool ça nous avance
vachement c'est pas comme si on savait
déjà enfin le truc c'est que ouais ouais
mon petit steven ça nous avance un peu
convergent historiquement le principe d'
actualiser m'a justement contribué à
faire de la géologie une science parce
que c'était pas gagné à la base en avant
le double est inculte les géologues
pensait qu'au commencement dieu créa la
terre lundi du coup certains ont tenté
même de faire coïncider les observations
géologiques et le grand dégât des eaux
de nouilles williams buckland le chef de
file de cette école de pensée qui
faisait largement consensus à l'époque
noyer même la géologie comme
l'auxiliaire et la servante de la
religion selon gould c'était carrément
une enquête quasi théologique qui
faisaient plus à montrer la grâce de
dieu qu'à comprendre les processus
naturels c'est la gueule et ses
disciples qui ont dit que bon allez il
ya un temps pour la religion un temps
pour les cailloux sauf en arabie
saoudite et qu'on allait plutôt prendre
modèle sur la physique donc c'est au
19ème que la géologie a commencé à
devenir une science ses rangs pas si
vieux que ça on joue les fêtes courtin
il ya plein d'autres rebondissements
autour de cette théorie de l'actualité
notamment quand on apprend qu'un de ses
concepts violent le 2
même principe de la thermodynamique et
contredit la théorie de l'évolution de
darwin ce qui est plutôt bas l'eau parce
que laguiole et darwin était super pote
et leur théorie n'était pas compatible
mais c'est pas le sujet de cette vidéo
et j'aurais peut-être l'occasion d'y
revenir dans un épisode dédié parce que
je trouve ça vraiment hyper intéressant
et si jamais ça vous dit le faites moi
signe dans les commentaires d'ici là je
vous glisse quelques petites références
sur le curieux sur le curieux dans la
description dans la description
donc voilà pour résumer il ya autant de
sites lange et aux logiques
d'antidépresseurs dans le sens d'un
youtube au cycle de l'eau de la zot du
carbone les cyclos climatique le cycle
démarre et le cyclope polyphème ma
bicyclette et le cycle des roches
combien de fois il vous reste plus qu'à
apprendre ce schéma parker pour obtenir
votre 1er dan de géologie si vous voulez
tester vos nouvelles connaissances et
vous essayer à la géologie en vrai sur
le terrain le muséum d'histoire
naturelle a sorti un nouveau programme
de science participative autour des
cailloux qui s'appelle vigie terre et
que je trouve hyper cool je préviens
c'est pas du tout un placement de
produit ne m'ont pas rémunérés pour ça
le principe c'est qu'on se balade dans
la nature et si jamais on croise des
caillons rigolos ou remarquables ou des
trucs comme ça on remplit une petite
fiche genre de fiches d'identité du
caillou et après on l'envoie en ligne
sur la plateforme de visiteurs et ça
sert à des scientifiques derrière donc
c'est ça qui est intéressant budgétaire
c'est un peu le pokémon gold la géologie
finale merci infiniment pour tous vos
dons sur youtube et hippie vous êtes des
gens formidables je vous aime follement
pour la prochaine vidéo on va élever un
peu le débat ça risque de vous faire un
peu un peu bizarre mais mais ça va être
cool et d'ici là bonne fête à toutes les
pédiluves
[Musique]
j'aime toujours pas ça